Women entrepreneurs currently are
getting about 2.5% of all venture
capital and it's not the only source of
funding,
but it's a really great indicator of how
we fare in space.
And that's a fairly commonly understood
statistic.
But the statistic that I like to
feature,
which is the one that nobody ever talks
about is what percentage of funding is
actually going to women of color.
Um,
and that's a much more dismal number.
That's actually depending on what study
you look at,
it's between 0.1% or 0.2% which is to
say that women of color and companies
founded by women of color aren't really
even statistically relevant at this
point.
The fact that women of color and
companies founded by women of color
don't really even play in the space is
particularly jarring if you think about
the fact that most companies in this
country are actually founded by women of
color.
So it's bad that we're not getting
funding,
but it's particularly bad given that we
seem to be the source of innovation.
And probably the most entrepreneurial
community of all venture capital is,
I often call it like the house flipping
version of investments,
right?
Like house flipping shows.
It has become the most popular,
the most visible,
the most sort of prolific version of
investing that's out there or even of
capital sources,
but there's way more to the world of
investing and of securing capital than
just venture capital,
right?
There's long view investments,
there's debt,
there's crowd funding.
There are many different options when it
comes to getting funding,
but the one that dominates the headlines
is venture capital.
You get to be on the cover of things.
When you secured a big series a,
you don't really get a whole lot of
price when you've secured a line of
credit or alone.
It's just not perceived as sexy.
And yet companies need debt in order to
be successful.
Companies that are women led tend to be
more successful at getting crowdfunding
dollars than they are at getting venture
capital dollars.
So in these areas of funding that don't
get a lot of publicity or actually
really critical because they are doing a
better job of servicing women owned
businesses.
Um,
and so the thing that I always tell
founders is that vc might be for you,
it might not be,
but let's not romanticize what it is and
how it works.
Please do not take venture capital from
any investor no matter what terms are
giving you,
unless you're willing to be fired from
your own company,
which was what happens to a lot of
people who end up taking venture
capital.
The bottom line for me is that there are
many different sources of capital.
They are,
it's not a one size fits all regime and
we get fed one single product and the
reality is,
is a smart founder has to look around to
see what their other options are.
And I would say that this is not just a
nice to have this as a critical,
critical thing.
And part of the reason that I worry
about that,
there's a hack in my book,
um,
that comes from an amazing investor
called dawn Rayvon.
And he talks in the book about how he
knows how this movie's going to end,
which is this idea that we don't have
enough women and people of color getting
that,
for example.
And what I'm worried about and what he's
worried about is that in 10 years we're
going to look back at the statistics and
we're going to see that we had too many
women and people of color excepting
blindly horrible terms and horrible
venture capital packages.
And in 10 years when we look back,
what's that going to produce?
It's going to produce a whole series and
maybe even a whole generation of
entrepreneurs that were just
proportionately more likely to fail.
And I worry that in 10 years when we
look back at a statistic like that,
people aren't going to blame an
unbalanced capital stock.
They're not going to blame the fact that
people should have taken debt and they
didn't.
They're going to look at stats that
simply say that women and people of
color fail at a greater rate than anyone
else,
and I want that not to be the end of our
movie.
Some of my favorite alternatives in
terms of getting funding are things like
loans are things like lines of credits,
uh,
but there are some that are even less
impactful to your business.
There are a little more work,
but the country is now speckled all over
the country.
I can't think of a state that doesn't
have competitions that doesn't have
pitch events where you can go spend a
little bit of time and energy and get
money for your company,
especially in those early days because
you tell a good story because you have a
great idea and especially money that
doesn't actually have to require that
you give away equity in your company.
Another one of my favorite sources of
funding is a crowdfunding and there are
a couple different kinds,
right?
There's crowdfunding where you give
people t shirts,
are you pre sell whatever product you're
trying to manufacturer.
In that case,
you're not giving up any equity.
You're giving people goodwill,
you're giving people product,
you're giving people a sneak preview
into what you're working on.
And in exchange,
you're getting meaningful capital.
Women tend to be disproportionately more
successful at crowdfunding campaigns.
Um,
there are different studies that say why
that might be.
And I suspect that it's because their
social networks are strong.
And I also suspect it's because we're
shut out of other forms of capital,
but there's also equity crowd funding,
or you are actually giving a piece of
your company away,
much like you're doing with venture
capital.
But in the equity crowdfunding space,
the terms tend to be better,
so you're not giving away as much and
you're not giving away nearly as much
control.
Okay.